ted robbins is a comedian and he's with
us now hi ted
good morning kay nice to speak to you
yeah and you too tell me what happened
to you
well again the similarities between what
happened to christian ericsson
and batteries moamba are similar to me
in some ways
in that um we were both in front of
thousands of people
it was the opening night of the phoenix
knights
tour for red nose day for comic relief
um
and uh with peter k and all the cats
coming back and it was for coming we're
going to do 15 nights
leading up to it i had some cardiac
problems which i knew about
and i kind of i don't know whether it
was wise or not but i managed to beg my
surgeon to
force all the uh surgery and uh the
operations
to let me do the show he said well you
you're okay for now
um and he kind of let me do it and in a
way it turned out it was good because
i got up on stage i did three minutes
playing the the character dan perry who
burton the phoenix club down and then i
just went
you know and it was 30 000 people and um
i didn't get one or two last before i
went but the fortunate thing was
if you're going to have one of these the
best place to have it it
apart from a hospital is in front of a
load of people 30 000
and as the footballers have a full
medical team nearby
um there's bound to be somebody in the
audience who knows what to do in my case
there's a wonderful paramedic from leeds
ex royal army medical corps called gary
loker
he's become like an adopted son to me
and he had the witch but everyone was
laughing really because they thought
i just you just go with cardiac arrest
it's not like a heart fail
it's not like a heart attack it's
cardiac arrest which literally means
cardiac the heart a rest stop so you go
down
and that's it the heart just
defibrillates and it doesn't beat
and unless somebody either gives cpr
you're pressing the chest
or unless somebody gets the um uh
defibrillator onto you very very quickly
you know within 10 minutes you're a
garment and every minute counts and
gary aided by a wonderful heart surgeon
well vascular surgeon
called mr donald adam i'm giving
michelle's house here who do great work
um so how lucky was i they they had the
wit
to jump on the stage and gary pumped
with um
donald pumped my heart for 15 minutes
broke
all my ribs 12 ribs and a cracked
sternum i i think i held the record at
wooden shore
hospital again a wonderful cardiac
center and um
you know i was so lucky they got me back
but um
my main thing is it has been helping to
spread the word about everyone learning
cpr you know
um what do you remember
about before and then what do you
remember about
afterwards well before k
i i had this terrible kind of
premonition
a kind of feeling nothing but something
was wrong and i knew something was wrong
but a cardiac arrest again isn't like
a heart attack you don't get the chest
pains the great power
that's a completely different thing when
the arteries block up
i just had this sort of strange feeling
and the night before i said to dave
spikey
who plays um who plays the jerry
sinclair
um i said to you know that if i fall
down tomorrow
it's not a gag and he was a bit taken
aback you know
and i told dave you see he actually was
a a trained
is a highly qualified um hematologist
at bolton uh hospital for years and
years before his comedy career
known fact so i knew he'd know something
about it
and when it happened i remember walking
backwards and forwards and uh
under the stage and all the lads paddy
mcguinness and
steve edge and and everyone said
something's wrong with ted because i
normally can't shut me up
as you can see and here and i just had
this
kind of fit i texted my wife judy who's
in the audience
my daughter was there my sister kate uh
nieces nephews emiliator
all this star studded cast and of course
he was in front of lenny henry
uh john bishop uh richard curtis you
know
and thirty thousand people and um
i was very very lucky so it happened i
remember going up
the steps underneath the stage because
the idea was then petty was
banged up in strange ways prison just
opposite the road from manchester united
and the gag was i was going to come up
and do a bit of a midnight shot you know
ram radio as i called it
and uh the music started which was
prodigies
fire starter which i never want to hear
again in my life
and i got up i thought i'm okay and then
i remember
i got through three minutes and i
thought this was going okay i was
getting a few laughs you know
and uh i had to step over towards some
giant flamethrowers we're going to do
i'm going to re-light the fire you know
we take that um
a song and we've rewritten the lyrics
peter cade written with me
for me um with gary barlow's blessing
and
i thought i've got to get over there
because we're going to sing i'm going to
re-light the fire
boom big flames and all i remember
thinking and i've been worried for a
long while
was a deep feeling of peace and
restfulness
and i thought oh i'm just gonna lie down
and the analogy i use
kay is it was like you know you've got a
very busy day
it's quite late at night you've been to
a wedding or a you know
party or whatever that feeling you get
to your bed
and it's dark it's two o'clock in the
morning and the fresh sheets and you go
oh just going to get into bed and i just
i thought i just laid down
um but unfortunately i did well i didn't
i just went bang out
and then i don't remember anything i
can't say i saw the white light until
i'd like to
see it but i do remember feeling a great
feeling of peace and
um just oh yeah like it's all over
yeah but thankfully there was somebody
there that managed to know what was
going on
and resuscitated you ted we're out of
time but a fascinating story love to
chat to you again in more detail
sometime but we've got to move on now
thanks so much for taking the
thanks jay thanks a lot see ya thanks a
lot